greetings earthlings my name is quest
love and this is
my wired auto complete interview
i am definitely afraid to google myself
even if i have to look for something i
will type quest love because i don't
want to see
what the uh so me doing this is facing
my biggest fear
what quest love that's a good one what
is in quest love's
hair this is a good question i'm known
for
my humongous afro i come from a family
of chia pets
the more you try to cut my hair the more
that it grows
i think that people want to know is the
object that
normally is in my hair which is the afro
pick i keep it there
because uh my scalp often
itches one time my afro got me in
trouble is uh
i went to the strip club in atlanta the
first time they made it rain
eighty dollars fell right in the hair
between the cr the crest of my afro pick
[Laughter]
and my afro and the second i went to
take it to to give to like the nearest
person
like security was on me in like three
seconds like ah we got that we got that
even on my body i couldn't touch it what
is course love's real name
my real name is amir
khalid thompson if i know a person of
arabic descent is
asking me what my full name is i will
say amir
khalif thompson i got my hero
prince he cold called me at a studio
once so i pick up
the phone he's like hello prince i was
like
wait is this you and this is back when
we didn't know if we were allowed to
still call him his name or not
inside secret he he's he's still that
black people call him prince
because we weren't going to try and
pronounce that symbol
he's like i'm calling you prince because
you know that's what your name means
right
and then uh i'll say four years later
when i was at a concert
he was singing the song sign of the
times and there's a
really famous line uh fall in love get
married have a baby
we'll call him nate if it's a boy he
knew i was on a blind date he changed
the lyric to fall in love
get married have a baby we'll name him
amir if he's funky
and he kind of looked at me and like i
knew my date was really impressed like
yeah that's right friends thinks i'm
funny
what drums does quest love play uh love
week
uh i started off on a ludwig set my very
first real drum set
at the age of eight for the beginning
part of my career
i went with yamaha because that was like
the biggest name
but i learned early in life that
sometimes like the biggest name
the most popular name doesn't suit you
well
i like a really trashy dirty sound
to my drums so oftentimes like drum
makers will
go for these long drawn out stories of
like they went to a particular
forest and japan to chop down this
particular type of tree that's like real
expensive like
this drum is worth ninety thousand
dollars if we use this particular type
of wood and da da da da da
i'll go along like oh it's really
interesting but i'd never play that
stuff so
like i have about 70 drum sets right now
which i never touch because i want the
cheap
high school version like i want i want
their lowest
most accessible drum like that to me is
the sound of
america's garage and i like that what
type of headphones does
questlove use okay so really it it
depends
when i'm djing depending on what my hair
situation is you need a
sort of a durable set of headphones
because i'm known to break them
if they like stretch out too much or
whatever so audio technica
m50x that's the specific brand that i
use they're high quality
however when i'm on stage i use
uh custom in-ear mics by the one and
only jerry harvey
audio they are the best in-ear monitors
ever
my favorite part of getting into your
microphone customs is you have to get
the foam
uh put in your ear so it's like a weird
feeling
it's like taking pancake batter and
someone just like
squeezing it in your ear and then you
know and
i'm i'm weird i'm sorry where does quest
love live
i'm a rolling stone i was born in
philadelphia
i still have property in philadelphia
ever since the tonight show
i've relocated to manhattan
in the dawning of uh covet 19 and
quarantining i've done something i never
thought i'd do before
i used to make fun of everyone every
professional every author and actor and
director i knew that
got that place uh in upstate new york
and now i've become that person it's not
a farm it's not a ranch
i think my girlfriend likes to call it a
chateau it's an artist community
when i drive drive up that i feel like
i'm in the beginning of a pee-wee's
playhouse like it's like a
fantasy land thing it's kind of cool
where to buy
the quest love cheesesteak good question
at most
live nation venues and uh my hometown of
philadelphia
philadelphia phillies my cheesesteak is
made of impossible meat
i'm not a vegan i'm not a vegetarian but
i do want to eat
uh way better so this would have came
out way earlier but i had to strike a
deal with amoroso
to make the rolls because if it's not on
an amoroso bread it's not a cheesesteak
from philly i don't care what anyone
says you can't put on our baghead
okay the quest love supreme podcast i
taught at nyu
for about six years it was just 25
students a lot of my
students are actually notable uh people
right now in the industry uh
you guys know maggie rogers he was one
of my students one day
my manager told me like well instead of
spewing this knowledge that you have
on just 25 kids a year why don't you
make it national so course love supreme
is uh
my podcast with my friends and we just
we just
talk music and pop culture it's not just
music it's acting it's film it's just
everything pop culture politics and
everything so
you can hear it practically anywhere
where you get podcasts
okay what hi hats does questlove use
full disclosure again i
like there's a very specific trashy
dirty
unprofessional sound i like kind of like
taking
brand new jeans and really destroying
them so that they look used and worn
that's what i do with my drums and with
my symbols
i will just get very very old zildjian
symbols
there's a guy in chicago named sonny
berman
and he does these custom he'll take the
symbols he'll destroy them
he'll cut holes in them they'll just
make them sound like trash
cans and often times uh i will use that
but the company i endure zildjian they
have a
a brand called uh fx stack which is the
same thing
they uh poke holes in the in the symbols
to give it more
bite more edge to it so those those are
the symbols that i use
what is quest love's vinyl collection
when i was five years old
a complete stranger asked me what type
of music i like and she brought me
my first three records in a record
player i found the note that she wrote
to my parents
like i love amir he's so cute i want to
buy him records
and she wrote it on a cocktail napkin
and i found that note like two weeks ago
and i put it on my instagram and i
wanted to find this woman her name was
ellie she lived in portland maine
they just found her so i guess i get a
chance to thank her because now i own
200 000 records
she planted a seed that
sort of grew out of control and now i
need to buy houses just to stack my
records
[Laughter]
what quest love lost i can't believe
this is actually on google like
i don't know what i lost i i i don't
recall any bet
i've ever lost or if i ever lost like
my oh i've lost my luggage oh i lost
weight
[Laughter]
wait as i'm thinking of real time
everyone on the side is like
i was like oh yeah i did early 2018
i was a very dangerous morbid uh
400 and like
15 16 pounds a lot of people in my
genre and whatnot they were sort of
succumbing to
strokes and heart attacks and i didn't
want to be that cliche
i want to live to the age of 90 and see
my full life through
i'm at the happiest ever been in my life
i will say that
quarantining i know that people
uh got into the habit of panic eating
and
my girlfriend is not having that nothing
will ever be
the moment when my band saw me they
all put on like five pounds and i took
off like 60.
so of course of course love yacht rock
all right here's the thing
my friendship with anthony bourdain
sparked
because of his hatred for yacht rock
music when i met anthony bourdain
i asked him i was like is it true that
you fired three chefs in your kitchen
because they were listening
to billy joel and he says no i hung a
sign
up saying i will fire you if you listen
to billy joel
in my kitchen and they defiantly put
billy joel
on so i fired him to me that was like oh
challenge accepted so whenever bourdain
would come on this
on the tonight show he would ask like
what walkout music are you going to play
for me
and i tell him something like whatever
like yeah
do some led zeppelin songs he's like
yeah yeah something real cool and then
whenever he walks out i just play billy
joel
just to get him angry when he passed
away i figured the best way
to pay tribute to him in the way that
really described our friendship
like me getting the last word was i made
him
uh like a 700 song yacht rock playlist
on my spotify it's one of my favorite
playlists like jimmy
jimmy fallon's obsessed with this
playlist like it's it's cool
i dig it all yacht rock fans just know
that i'm the king of yatra
what of course love's favorite albums
doing quarantining i
i did this challenge and on my spotify
i put in order my 100 favorite records
now i'll just tell you my top 10
but all 100 in there so my number 10
is stevie wonder's music of my mind my
number nine is a tribe called quest
midnight marauders
my number eight is 1999 by prince number
seven
is voodoo by d'angelo number six
is de la soul is dead number five
is rufus and chaka khan's ask rufus my
number four
is michael jackson's off the wall my
number three
is fantastic volume one by sloan village
number two
is it takes a nation of millions to hold
us back by public enemy
and my number one record of all time is
person in person live
1976 by the average white band
google went kind of light on me because
i think when any of my other friends do
this like it's the meanest things ever
so it shows me that people might
actually like me
so that's cool